Call of Duty Modern Warfare in 2019
delivered a very different take on the
franchise introducing a year of
memorable moments like the nuke event
and Haunting of verdansk and kicked off
The free-to-play War Zone all while
Gathering a whole new Call of Duty fan
base with Modern Warfare 2 finally here
here's everything you need to know
Modern Warfare 2 picks up the plot three
years after the end of Modern Warfare
2019 when Captain Price formed Task
Force 141 and stopped a nuke launch in
verdance it's a sequel to the reboot
rather than a remake of the original
Modern Warfare 2 so we don't know
exactly how it will play out this time
fingers crossed that ghost doesn't get
absolutely fragged again though many
familiar faces return such as soap gas
ghost and price and there are some new
faces like Colonel Alejandro Vargas the
story involves the usual globetrotting
Special Operations you'd expect from
Call of Duty with a few new things to
consider many of the missions are
inspired by fan favorite Call of Duty
levels such as all gilded up and the
plot involves an American strike on a
high level 4 in general resulting in
that hostile country Contracting out
worldwide retaliation through the Los
Alamos drug cartel based in Mexico now
spec ops did not have a lot of details
until now with the Cod folks sending us
a bunch of Deeds on what you can expect
with the revamped game mode for example
additional special apps missions will
arrive as raids in season 1. there will
be three featured Missions at launch all
taking place in Al mazara the new war
zone map there's a bad situation which
is a stealth Mission you'll infiltrate a
town at night for Intel and evidence all
by alcatala there's vehicle Escape where
you'll navigate through winding streets
of a suburb trying to destroy Sam
turrets and Observatory defense a
survival mission where you defend the
observatory from increasingly difficult
waves of enemies trying to detonate
bombs operators can spend cash to get
items like killstreaks self-revive kits
and armor plates the operators in Spec
Ops will have access to a backpack as
well to store equipment and use one of
three kits similar to multiplayer perk
packages which are assault Medic or
engineer based each has their own play
Styles and sets of pros and cons as you
might image You Can level up these kits
by earning Stars through missions and
Mission related challenges Activision
strongly recommends you complete all
three missions with Max stars and to
have at least one kit leveled up to rank
5 before the raids are introduced in
season one which by the way raids being
part of spec ops are a direct
continuation of the campaign if you
decide a pre-order is right for you
players can get through the campaign a
week before the full launch guild-free
that they didn't fall behind in
multiplayer now alright we know you came
here for the guns so let's talk about
the new ways gunsmith Works weapons are
grouped into platforms now with the
receiver being the base of weapon trees
by leveling the receiver and adding
attachments within a single tree you can
build an SMG lmg battle rifle sniper
rifle Ursa monstrosity in between fair
warning the system was buried under a
few menus in the beta also keep in mind
that there are weapon specific
attachments and Universal attachments
Universal attachments only need to be
unlocked once and then they can be used
across multiple platforms eliminating
some repetitive grinding weapon specific
attachments are designed to make each
platform take on more unique roles
weapon blueprints also make a return or
players can buy weapon vaults which get
you every attachment and new cosmetic
appearance for a platform also you can
test your builds before going head to
head with other players best meta
leading creations at the offline firing
range which spots three firing Lanes a
climbing area and targets at different
distances oddly enough a lot of the new
gear does feel inspired by Rainbow Six
Siege like networked cameras drill
charges and decoys the important thing
to note is that the sandbox from 2019 is
still here with multiple test videos
already done by the community and us
check out our 18 things you didn't know
about Modern Warfare 2 multiplayer to
see what we mean now multiplayer has a
lot of customization options this time
around with PC sporting something along
like what 500 adjustments as well as
Ultra wide support console fans
including the previous gen will have a
fov slider this time around the game is
also cross play so it remains to be seen
if this gives PC players an advantage
now there's so much to talk about with
multiplayer this time around so let's
start with battle maps Modern Warfare
2019 leaned heavily into ground war and
large-scale 32-32 player battles return
the ground war is now only one of the
modes under battle maps in the beta we
already saw another Mode called Invasion
which pitted teams of players and Bots
against each other and by the time
Warzone launches you'll probably be
familiar with many of its locations like
serif Bay from the beta in fact battle
maps are intentionally meant to test
Warzone 2.0 points of interest ahead of
launch in battle maps every building can
be explored and several of the modes
involve Bots with developers suggesting
it's possible they can go up to 300 Bots
with a hundred players at some point the
vehicle roster has been expanded with
with multiple types of quads cars
armored trucks heavy and light tanks
helicopters and even boats the largest
transport the heavy Chopper has an
interior that players can walk around
and fight out of players have more
interactions with vehicles this time
around including the ability to lean out
destroy Parts such as blowout tires
which impacts handling and mantle or
hang off them another unique aspect of
Battle maps is how many of the new
tacticals lethals and field upgrades
were designed with combined arms and
Water Combat in mind many gadgets have
alternate modes and behaviors such as
how proximity mines float inflatable
decoys strike a swimming post DDOS and
shock sticks will shut down some
vehicles and trophy systems will stick
to vehicles in order to stop incoming
projectiles on the Move core maps
consist of tighter 6v6 engagements but
despite being described as more
straightforward we found they were still
fairly large in the beta with a lot of
different routes through them and plenty
of vertical space core maps sport a few
competitive no respawn modes such as
knockout where teams need to hold a bag
for 60 seconds or eliminate the enemy
team to win there's also prisoner rescue
where one team scores points by rescuing
two hostages while the other team tries
to eliminate them the usual suspects
also return here like domination TDM and
hardpoint third person mode is there for
many of these modes and adds some flavor
like shoulder swapping but it doesn't
significantly change how the rounds play
out because players can still go to
first person when aiming down sights now
Warzone 2.0 is free to play and releases
on November 16th a few weeks after the
campaign in multiplayer almazra runs on
the same engine and mechanics as
multiplayer and is a complete reboot
with the first war zone remaining its
own experience that also means that your
previous war zone skins guns and
purchases won't carry over almazara is
the biggest Call of Duty map in the
franchise with 18 point points of
interest and because of that Sports a
new multi-circle close mechanic with
players needing to win within several
individual circles before they close
down and they all fight in the final
Circle it can support up to 150 players
with additional AI Loadout drops have
been replaced by the shop which are buy
stations where you can buy more stuff
than the first war zone which includes
weapons and your own gunsmith Creations
when purchased they replace your entire
looted inventory and this also continues
to be where you buy Squad mates back AI
is a big part of Modern Warfare 2 and
Warzone features with both Bots
scattered around the map and strongholds
which are areas full of tougher AI
combatants guarding higher tier loot
Bots will not chase you though so you
can fight or ignore them if you die
during a match you will go to the new
Gulag which is modeled much closer to
the previous gunfight Mode in Modern
Warfare 2019 than the current War zones
Gulag teams of two start with nothing
and loot the area before either winning
to gain a second chance back to the war
zone map or getting knocked out of the
round the gulag also has a tough AI boss
called the Jailer who can show up and if
both teams cooperate to take them down
all that means that both teams can go
back to the war zone match players keep
any gear found in the gulag so they
don't drop back onto the main map a
Sitting Duck now not a lot has been said
about DMZ yet it's a mysterious mode
that we know to be a extraction mode and
it seems to have a gear collection
mechanic and rumors still have it pegged
as a potential escape from tarkov style
freeform mode but we'll have to wait and
see very little has been confirmed about
Modern Warfare 2 post launch Warzone of
course will have a number of Seasons as
expected Activision has been rumored to
be looking into moving away from the
yearly Call of Duty cycle which would
mean more than a year of DLC for Modern
Warfare 2 but only if that winds up
being true they have said that premium
Call of Duty content will come out in
2023 so we just don't know yet other
Rumors in speculation and to add older
Modern Warfare 2 maps being released
post-launch but none of this is
confirmed the dev blog described it as a
years-long journey to come with our
players now Modern Warfare 2 and Warzone
are multi-platform releases including
PS4 PS5 Xbox One Xbox series X and S and
PC PC including steam by the way it
supports cross play and cross
progression now this time around there
is a multi-week launch with Early Access
campaign on October 20th a full launch
on October 28th a war zone 2.0 and DMZ
launch on November 16th and raids are
coming with season 1 starting December
14th that was an intense amount of
information so most importantly don't
forget to have fun and stick around for
upcoming reviews test videos and guides
keep an eye out for videos from myself
and our other Cod experts on staff Aaron
Samson and Decker I'm David and I'll see
you all out there in battle thanks for
watching